good morning John it's Tuesday and I
couldn't care less what they of the
month it is or even what month it is
truth to be told I'm getting kind of
scared about the end of Brotherhood dew
point oh I keep looking at calendars and
January 1st keeps getting closer but
there are several orders of business
that I need to take care of first if
you're on YouTube
look up here I made a new little banner
thing second you may be wondering why
there are words on my hands that's
because I'm the dork and I'm going to
choose not to explain myself third the
first newsletter to do with the secret
project is going out tonight so you
better send up now if you're gonna sign
up because otherwise you're not gonna
get on the newsletters now this isn't
going to be the primary organizational
newsletter that will come later but this
will be the introduction to the secret
project
Guha but I can't say one thing to
everyone keep your eyes open on the 17th
of December because that is the day oh
that's the day so keep your eyes on
YouTube on the 17th of December you
can't participate if you're not on the
email list I'm sorry about that
but if you're on the email list and your
sign up for YouTube eeep the 17th as
clear as you can because that's the day
when we're gonna need you and we're
possibly going to need you to put in a
significant amount of time all of you
and that's it right now I've got a
pretty good number of you go
nerdfighters Chris Rock
ever since my video last week I keep
wanting to punch the camera I felt like
that was a good effect a couple of
people said that they thought that
camera was gonna go over and they wanted
to know what that looked like
now oh not quite ohh it kind of stings a
little bit that's what it looks like
when I do that maybe I should do the
rest of the video from here um what is
the rest of the video maybe you can play
a game this game is called random things
in my room lucky cat
Jeb black pirate kitty try Dube he goes
that's camp search ok those last two
things are actually things that I wanted
to share with you guys this shirt was
sent to us from Eagles Nest Camp because
of our recent interaction with them and
they signed it and Sharon made a horse
and it says this is a horse
I remember Nonie she was fun so that's
pretty awesome isn't it and the try tube
came from Tom Stone that the original
secrets
and I don't know what's in it but it
says that we can't open it until we
watch his video on the 31st of December
I am actually really very very excited
about opening this it's very light so my
first thought is a poster of some kind
but I'm not gonna get to find out with
of a new year hopefully you guys will
see me open this and you'll find out
what it is - but John I'm not entirely
sure what we're gonna do in the last day
I know it's my day but if you asked if
you were there - even though you're not
going to be there because you're gonna
be in Chicago okay well I guess that's
my video for today secret project sign
up I left this in the email so the
sooner you can sign up the better if you
not signed up by Friday it's gonna be
kind of hard to participate we need
every one of you and that is all for
today John I will see you tomorrow